J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, c'est un sujet central à notre époque. Il était grand temps de se pencher dessus proprement avec un chercheur spécialisé.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler de l'extrême droite, de fascisme, de populisme et compagnie. On va parler de la manière dont l'extrême droite avance masquée, de comment l'identifier et enfin, on va aussi se pencher sur sa rhétorique bien particulière.
Pour l'anecdote, je me souviens avec nostalgie qu'il y a une dizaine d'années, j'avais été invité dans un podcast international et on me demandait d'expliquer la Belgique.
Je me rappelle que à l'heure où l'extrême droite montait chez nos voisins et où le Brexit rabattait les cartes, je me souviens que j'expliquais à la personne qui m'interviewait
que l'extrême droite existait en Belgique, mais qu'elle était très minoritaire.
Et à l'époque, pour rappel, en effet, il y avait trois députés Vlaams Belang à la Chambre. Trois. Aujourd'hui, il y en a vingt et on connaît la situation aux États-Unis et chez nos voisins.
Sans plus attendre, François Debras. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec François Debras. Bonjour François.
Bonjour.
François, tu es politologue, chercheur ici en Belgique. Tu es maître assistant à la Haute École Libre de Mosane, professeur associé à l'Université de Liège.
Tu es chargé de cours, donc également à l'Université de Namur, à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles. Tu es partout en Belgique francophone.
Oui.
Est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour celles et ceux qui ne te connaissent pas encore
? Et voilà, en particulier les sujets qui t'ont le plus travaillé, sur lesquels tu as le plus travaillé et ce qui t'a amené à,
à te passionner pour ces sujets-là.
Oui, donc, je suis un politologue un petit peu particulier puisque moi, mon domaine d'expertise, c'est l'analyse des discours.
Qui renvoie directement à mon cursus. En fait, j'ai fait un bachelier en communication et journalisme,
et puis un master en sciences politiques et sociales et donc une thèse de doctorat sur l'analyse des discours d'extrême droite qui liait vraiment mes deux passions, l'analyse des discours et la question de la politique.
Et donc ma thèse de doctorat se concentrait sur l'utilisation du terme démocratie dans les discours d'extrême droite, c'est-à-dire en fait en Allemagne, l'AfD, en Autriche, le FPÖ et en France, le Rassemblement national.
Cette réflexion, elle est née en fait d'un long cheminement où, théoriquement, on a souvent opposé extrême droite et démocratie en expliquant que l'extrême droite était contre la démocratie.
Et moi, j'ai essayé de retourner la table en me demandant : tiens, quand j'écoute ces partis politiques d'extrême droite, ils mobilisent très souvent le terme de démocratie.
Donc j'ai retourné la table, je me suis dit : quand ils me parlent de démocratie, qu'est-ce qu'ils me racontent ? Donc ça, c'est mon travail au quotidien.
Vraiment, le cœur de mon travail, c'est analyser les discours d'extrême droite. Après, plus globalement, j'étudie aussi les discours
complotistes, mais l'idée, c'est toujours la même, c'est de se poser la question : derrière les mots, quelles sont les stratégies rhétoriques qui existent ?
Derrière les mots, quelles sont les émotions que l'on essaye de véhiculer ? Et comment est-ce qu'un discours nous amène parfois à adhérer à une conclusion qui n'est pas évidente de prime abord ?
Donc c'est vraiment essayer de déceler les idéologies et les stratégies qui se cachent derrière les mots.
Ça marche pour les discours d'extrême droite, pour les discours complotistes, mais même plus largement aujourd'hui, je fais aussi de l'analyse de discours politiques au sens large.
Donc voilà un peu mon domaine, dans lequel j'évolue.
Ouais, ouais. C'est fascinant parce que, en préparant cette interview, j'ai un peu bugué en me rendant compte que sur presque cent épisodes, en fait, je me suis rendu compte qu'on n'a
jamais fait un épisode à proprement parler sur l'extrême droite, sur le fascisme.
Même si c'est vrai que voilà, un petit peu de traviole, mais analyse de discours avec Emmanuel Danblon, le complotisme avec Olivier Klein, la xénophobie avec François Gemenne, etc.
C'est vrai que c'est des thématiques qui, un petit peu, voilà, vont pénétrer l'ensemble des discussions sur tous ces sujets, c'est différent, la psychologie, l'analyse des discours, l'immigration.
Donc, tu disais, tu as beaucoup travaillé sur l'extrême droite, le fascisme. Je pense qu'on vit une période assez intéressante, assez fertile à cet égard.
Quand on fait une rétrospective, on va définir un petit peu tous ces termes, évidemment, mais quand on fait une rétrospective sur ces dix dernières années, depuis, j'dirais 2012,
qu'est-ce qui te frappe ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on observe de particulièrement remarquable par rapport, donc, à l'extrême droite en Occident ?
Moi, je pense que ce qui est intéressant, c'est d'observer, on pourrait dire, une double évolution de l'extrême droite qui est une évolution de sa rhétorique.
Aujourd'hui, on a une extrême droite qui a bien compris que elle voulait non pas rester marginale sur les bancs de la société ou de son régime politique.
Et elle veut vraiment aujourd'hui, et donc elle a une stratégie active pour essayer de siéger au sein des institutions et pour essayer d'exercer directement le pouvoir.
Et donc, pour ce faire, elle va adapter sa rhétorique, elle va adapter ses stratégies politiques. Elle ne va plus être dans de la simple opposition. Elle va essayer de
proposer et non plus de renverser les institutions, mais de les changer de l'intérieur. Et donc, pour ce faire,
elle va essayer de contourner tout un tas de législations qui, à l'origine, ont été mises en place pour lutter contre l'extrême droite.
Je pense notamment aux lois contre le racisme, contre la discrimination, contre le négationnisme. Donc l'extrême droite adapte sa rhétorique également.
Donc, on a une évolution en termes de stratégie. On n'est plus dans l'opposition frontale vis-à-vis des institutions, on veut les intégrer et on va, deuxième évolution, changer sa rhétorique pour contourner la législation.
Après, et je crois que c'est un élément qui est important aussi à mobiliser, quand on parle de l'extrême droite — malheureusement, j'ai envie de dire, les discours d'extrême droite ne sont pas le monopole des partis politiques d'extrême droite.
Et on voit aujourd'hui qu'on évolue dans ce que l'on pourrait qualifier dans la littérature comme une zone grise, c'est-à-dire que là où l'extrême droite adapte ses propos,
d'autres partis politiques, de droite ou de gauche, vont également intégrer les thèmes ou les sujets,
historiquement propres à l'extrême droite et discuter de ces sujets avec parfois un vocabulaire qui vient de l'extrême droite lui-même.
Donc, on est dans une période comme ça, de zone grise où c'est pas toujours évident de savoir
identifier un parti politique, voire bien plus que ça, des discours d'extrême droite qui ne sont pas donc le propre des partis politiques d'extrême droite. Moi, je travaille,
sur l'extrême droite dans différents pays européens, mais en Belgique spécifiquement, pour illustrer ce propos-là, souvent, on avance que,
on aurait, entre guillemets, de la chance, en Belgique francophone de ne pas avoir de partis politiques d'extrême droite institutionnalisés.
Mais je pense que si on n'a pas de partis politiques d'extrême droite institutionnalisés en Belgique francophone, c'est pas pour ça qu'il n'y a pas des discours d'extrême droite et des idéologies d'extrême droite qui existent
et qu'il faut aussi à la fois savoir qualifier et dénoncer.
On va revenir évidemment sur le cas de la Belgique francophone un peu plus tard. Bon, évidemment, là, voilà, tu dis que t'as une approche vraiment de l'analyse des discours.
Y aura évidemment, je pense, des choses à dire sur l'usage des réseaux sociaux, les Cambridge Analytica, les podcasts, etc.
'Fin, on va détailler. Y a beaucoup de choses à dire, évidemment, sur les quinze dernières années. Mais donc, on parle ici de l'extrême droite.
Tu le disais, y a eu une évolution vis-à-vis du positionnement, de comment ça avance. Là, c'est plus tellement dans des mouvements révolutionnaires, violents, militaires, des choses comme ça.
Et, du coup, ça fait qu'effectivement, des fois, on entend sur les plateaux télé des gens dire : « Mais non, le Rassemblement National n'est pas vraiment un parti d'extrême droite.
Ça n'est pas un appel à la violence. » Voilà, il fait écho à des choses comme le Troisième Reich qui est vraiment ouvertement violent.
Donc, est-ce que, voilà, on va poser la question de la définition tout de suite, hein. Est-ce qu'il y a eu un changement de définition à proprement parler ?
Comment est-ce que tu définis l'extrême droite ?
Alors, je pense qu'il y a pas une seule définition,
pour définir ce qu'est l'extrême droite. Y en a plusieurs et elles ont toutes leurs spécificités et elles ne sont pas nécessairement concurrentes les unes vis-à-vis des autres, mais il faut vraiment les voir comme les unes se renforçant,
les unes, les autres.
Une des premières définitions qu'on utilise pour définir l'extrémisme ou l'extrême droite, c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler un positionnement spatial, c'est-à-dire où on se positionne
dans un parlement ou sur la scène politique et médiatique par rapport aux autres partis politiques.
De façon relative, quoi.
De façon relative.
Plus à droite, le plus à droite.
Le parti le plus à droite serait l'extrême droite, le parti qui serait le plus à gauche serait le parti d'extrême gauche, ce qui est lié au positionnement aussi dans les parlements.
On regarde où peuvent s'asseoir les députés et on dit : « Ça, c'est l'extrême droite, ça, c'est l'extrême gauche. »
C'est quelque chose qu'on observe, par exemple, aux États-Unis où,
voilà, des gens qui sont des soc dem, des social-démocrates, des Bernie Sanders, etc., vont être qualifiés par certains commentateurs américains comme étant l'extrême gauche.
Oui.
On regarde ici, on fait : « Mais non. » C'est parfaitement modéré comme position.
Oui, donc c'est la position spatiale. En fait, elle est simple, donc facile à comprendre. On prend un axe gauche-droite et on positionne les acteurs les uns par rapport aux autres.
C'est un modèle, comme tu disais, aux États-Unis, mais qui est aussi mobilisé en France, par exemple. En France, pour qualifier, donc c'est le ministère de l'Intérieur qui
va donner des étiquettes aux partis politiques avant les élections pour pouvoir
aider les électrices et les électeurs à se positionner.
Et donc on étudie quels sont les partis politiques les plus proches les uns des autres en fonction de leur discours, de leur programme, de leur lien, par exemple, entre les militantes et les militants.
Et on va attribuer une étiquette en fonction des partis politiques. Sauf que, exactement comme tu l'as dit, ça va créer une certaine forme de relativisme.
C'est-à-dire que l'extrême droite aujourd'hui n'est peut-être pas la même que l'extrême droite il y a cent ans et l'extrême droite en Belgique n'est peut-être pas la même que l'extrême droite en Espagne ou en Roumanie ou en Angleterre.
Donc, y a d'autres éléments. Ça, c'est la définition spatiale, on pourrait dire. Et la deuxième, c'est ce qu'on appelle la définition axiologique.
C'est, on va revenir plutôt en mode shopping list, c'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir une liste de critères et on va évaluer ces critères.
Ces critères, y en a trois. Donc on va définir dans cette définition axiologique l'extrême droite comme un corpus idéologique construit autour de trois éléments centraux.
Le premier, c'est l'inégalitarisme. Le deuxième, c'est le nationalisme et le troisième, le sécuritarisme. Donc, on considère que c'est ces trois éléments idéologiques qui vont définir l'extrême droite.
Alors, rapidement, pour expliquer ce que sont ces trois éléments, le premier, l'inégalitarisme. L'extrême droite, dans la pensée d'extrême droite, on va considérer que les êtres humains seraient naturellement inégaux les uns par rapport aux autres.
Il y aurait des différences, des inégalités naturelles au sein de l'humanité. Historiquement, l'extrême droite va plutôt parler de prétendue race.
Donc, il y aurait des prétendues races au sein de l'humanité, il y aurait des races prétendument supérieures et d'autres qui seraient inférieures.
Ce discours raciste va donc évoluer également puisque dans les années, fin des années 80, début des années 90,
que ce soit en Belgique, en France ou dans d'autres États européens, on va avoir une législation qui va se mettre en place justement pour lutter contre l'incitation à la haine raciale.
Ce qu'on observe ces dernières années, c'est qu'en fait, ce discours que l'on pourrait qualifier de raciste biologique, concentré essentiellement sur la couleur de peau, la blancheur, va évoluer vers ce qu'on appelle un racisme culturel ou religieux.
C'est ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'on ne va plus utiliser le mot race, puisqu'on pourrait être soumis à des amendes et des peines d'emprisonnement.
Donc, on va changer son propos et on va plutôt parler de culture ou de religion. L'idée, c'est qu'il y a plus nécessairement des supérieurs et des inférieurs, mais il y aurait des assimilables et des non assimilables.
L'idée, c'est qu'on peut à la fois contourner la législation contre l'incitation à la haine raciale tout en, entre guillemets, disant la même chose que ce qu'on disait par le passé.
Autrement dit, on enferme des individus dans des cultures ou dans des religions. On va les hiérarchiser et on va les exclure en fonction de certains critères.
C'est ça. Un exemple qui me vient en tête, bon, évidemment, dans le contexte récent, c'est de plus en plus ambigu de savoir qui est-ce que ça concerne, mais je pense par exemple à un—
Un Alain Soral, par exemple, qui va déguiser son antisémitisme et son racisme vraiment éternel en employant des mots comme : « Non, je ne suis pas antisémite, je suis antisioniste. »
Oui, mais même plus, on le voit plus spécifiquement, par exemple, dans le domaine lié à la question migratoire.
Par exemple, les réfugiés ukrainiens seraient, selon certains,
présentateurs de JT en France ou des représentants politiques, les réfugiés ukrainiens seraient, entre guillemets, assimilables parce qu'ils auraient la même culture européenne ou histoire européenne que nous.
Ukrainiens, tu veux dire.
Ukrainiens.
Oui, oui, c'est ça. T'as inversé Ukrainiens et Syriens.
Ah oui. Ukrainiens seraient assimilables parce qu'ils auraient la même—
Oui, c'est ça.
Histoire culturelle ou la même histoire européenne que nous, alors que des réfugiés syriens, en l'occurrence, seraient inassimilables parce qu'ils viendraient d'une culture ou d'une religion musulmane.
Et on est toujours, en fait, que ce soit un racisme biologique ou culturel, dans cette idée d'essentialisme, parce que vous appartenez à telle culture ou à telle religion, vous ne pouvez pas comprendre nos valeurs.
Autrement dit, ce qu'on a pu entendre sur la scène médiatique, c'est de dire, entre guillemets : « Vous êtes un réfugié
syrien, vous êtes nécessairement donc musulman et vous ne pouvez donc nécessairement pas comprendre l'égalité homme-femme ou la laïcité.
» Donc, on enferme des individus dans des groupes. À l'origine, c'était des groupes prétendument raciaux. Aujourd'hui, c'est des groupes culturels ou religieux.
Donc on retrouve cet inégalitarisme, mais qui ne se construit plus aujourd'hui explicitement sur la notion de race, mais plutôt de culture et de religion.
Et donc, ce qui peut paraître un peu paradoxal, et peut-être qu'il y a des profs de français qui vont être furieux, mais on va naturaliser la culture, finalement.
Oui, c'est ça. On va lui donner à la culture, finalement, une essence, quelque chose d'indépassable. On ne dépasse pas sa culture d'origine.
Donc on ne sort pas de sa culture, on n'apprend pas des autres cultures, on n'échange pas ses cultures. C'est vraiment des blocs monolithiques et figés qui vont déterminer l'individu.
L'individu ne peut pas sortir de sa culture ou sa religion d'origine. Donc ça, c'est le premier critère, c'est l'inégalitarisme, qui est vraiment le cœur de la vision du monde de l'extrême droite.
À côté de cela, on a le deuxième critère qui est le—
L'inégalitarisme qui amène finalement à une légitimation d'une hiérarchisation et donc d'une domination quoi, puisqu'on est différents—
De racisme, de hiérarchisation, de domination et d'infériorisation des individus.
Puisqu'on est différents, il y en a forcément qui sont meilleurs que les autres.
Exactement.
Et puisqu'il y en a qui sont meilleurs que les autres, ils ont le droit d'écraser les autres.
Voilà, exactement. Deuxième critère, donc, c'est le nationalisme qui peut, on pourrait dire d'une certaine façon, découler du premier.
Si on considère qu'il y a des individus supérieurs et des individus inférieurs, alors on va imaginer la nation comme une communauté qui va rassembler un certain nombre d'individus perçus comme homogènes.
C'est-à-dire que dans la nation, on a une langue, une coutume, une tradition, une histoire. Et on va imaginer donc la communauté comme homogène, comme pure.
Et on va rejeter de cette communauté tout un ensemble d'individus qui seraient différents ou qui ne partageraient pas la même langue, la même histoire.
Là, on se rend compte aussi que ce nationalisme, il a évolué,
au fur et à mesure des années. À l'origine, l'extrême droite, c'est plutôt un nationalisme expansif ou agressif qui va être tourné vers l'extérieur, une augmentation des territoires, la conquête, etc.
Aujourd'hui, on a plutôt un nationalisme défensif. Et je le dis en simplifiant un petit peu, mais dans la rhétorique ou en politique, celui qui agresse est, entre guillemets, le méchant, celui qui
est la victime est, entre guillemets, le pauvre malheureux.
Et donc l'extrême droite va très bien comprendre cette logique-là et va retourner sa rhétorique. On va avoir un nationalisme défensif, c'est-à-dire qu'on ne va plus agresser autrui, mais on va se présenter comme devant protéger la nation.
On va vouloir protéger les traditions, protéger les coutumes, protéger la beauté de la langue, protéger le carnaval, les traditions de la nation.
Alors encore une fois, enfin, c'est petite subtilité, je dis pas que si on est pour l'enseignement du latin à l'école, on est d'extrême droite ou que si on veut garder le carnaval, on est d'extrême droite.
C'est un peu la logique du rectangle et du carré. C'est-à-dire que tous les carrés sont des rectangles, mais tous les rectangles ne sont pas des carrés.
Donc, c'est-à-dire qu'on peut être pour la défense du carnaval, ça fait pas forcément de nous quelqu'un d'extrême droite, mais l'extrême droite va très bien comprendre qu'elle peut investir ces sujets-là.
Quand tu parles du carnaval, tu penses à des trucs comme le— comment il s'appelle ce truc en Wallonie avec le gars qui a un piercing dans le nez ?
Oui, c'est ça. Oui, avec le lien sur—
Le sauvage, c'est ça, oui.
Oui, avec le sauvage du carnaval.
Quand tu disais carnaval, j'inventais des trucs beaucoup plus, justement, multiculturels, beaucoup plus ouverts sur le monde.
Ah non, non, pas du tout. Pas du tout, justement.
Oui, toi, tu pensais au carnaval.
Oui.
Ce carnaval-là, quoi.
Pour ne pas le citer. Ou alors, on va retrouver aussi le nom pour les vacances, quoi. Garder les vacances de Noël, les vacances de Pâques.
Oui, c'est ça, oui. La guerre contre Noël, en fait.
Oui. Donc on veut en fait protéger une certaine identité qui va être un élément de référence pour cette nation.
Figée dans le temps, éternelle, un conservatisme quand même très marqué.
Exactement. Donc l'inégalitarisme des groupes supérieurs, des groupes inférieurs. Si on a des groupes inférieurs, ils vont se définir par un ensemble de caractéristiques qu'il faut protéger des inférieurs.
Et comment est-ce qu'on les protège ? Par la troisième caractéristique, donc inégalitarisme, nationalisme et troisième caractéristique, le sécuritarisme.
L'extrême droite, en fait, va se définir par une certaine forme d'appétence pour l'ordre et la sécurité.
Il faudrait plus de frontières, plus de contrôle, plus d'armée, plus de police, des peines plus sévères, une peine prononcée égale une peine effectuée.
Alors, c'est la même chose que pour le nationalisme. C'est pas parce qu'on est en faveur d'un refinancement de la justice qu'on est nécessairement d'extrême droite.
Mais l'extrême droite joue systématiquement dans ces logiques-là. Pareil, c'est pas parce qu'on veut plus de police qu'on est forcément d'extrême droite, mais l'extrême droite joue systématiquement dans ces logiques-là.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait, on va avoir vraiment cette volonté d'ordre et de contrôle. Si l'on considère qu'on doit rester dans un groupe homogène et pur et qu'on est supérieur, alors il faut se protéger des inférieurs.
Et on va avoir cette volonté de systématiser des logiques beaucoup plus sécuritaires, de contrôle, de la société dans laquelle nous sommes.
C'est un outil indispensable pour l'extrême droite d'avoir l'usage de la force pour mettre en place ces politiques.
Voilà, c'est ça. Donc ça, c'est les trois caractéristiques de la définition axiologique, donc inégalitarisme, nationalisme et sécuritarisme.
Et pour revenir sur ce deuxième point, nationalisme, c'est une différence qui est revenue dans plusieurs interviews, c'est le constat que du côté belge francophone, on a plutôt une identité en creux.
On a un peu du mal à dire ce que ça veut dire être belge. On n'a pas une fierté incroyable, à part pendant les matchs de foot, évidemment.
Et inversement, du côté flamand, là, c'est très exacerbé, c'est Vlaams, c'est les drapeaux, Studio Anderlecht et tout ça, les trucs qui viennent un peu vraiment,
voilà, graver une identité, l'idée d'État-nation, le territoire, la langue, l'identité, l'histoire, tout ça, c'est la même chose.
On ne dépasse pas de Bruxelles de trente mètres avec du français ou si c'est le cas, ça les ennuie très fort.
Est-ce que, du coup, cette différence-là en apparence, en termes d'identité nationale, en termes d'identité en creux, identité revendiquée, etc.,
est un facteur qui fait que, voilà, on a effectivement une extrême droite
bien moins existante du côté francophone, en tout cas ouvertement assumée, institutionnelle ?
Alors, c'est un des facteurs qui peut expliquer l'absence de partis politiques d'extrême droite importants sur la scène politique francophone en Belgique, mais c'est peut-être pas le seul, il y en a d'autres.
Mais effectivement, c'est vrai qu'on retrouve cette absence d'identité francophone ou wallonne, on pourrait dire. Pourquoi ?
Parce que la Belgique, en fait, était dans un modèle à l'origine unitaire, où les élites, entre guillemets, parlaient français.
Et donc, on va avoir une identité flamande qui va
se construire justement dans un certain nombre de revendications historiques pour le droit de s'exprimer dans sa langue, d'avoir l'enseignement dans sa langue, de traduire les textes administratifs et la législation
dans sa langue, de reconnaître son histoire et sa culture.
Là où c'est vrai qu'on perçoit plutôt les francophones comme
des réactions par rapport à cette identité flamande. Ce qui peut expliquer l'absence d'extrême droite, mais je me limiterai pas à ça parce qu'on peut retrouver très bien des partis politiques d'extrême droite,
même si on les connaît moins parce qu'ils sont
moins présents, ils ont des résultats
électoraux très faibles.
Mais il y a des partis politiques d'extrême droite et des discours d'extrême droite et des discours nationalistes qui existent dans le sud du pays et qui vont jouer sur les coutumes, les traditions,
le paysage, la beauté de nos campagnes, etc. qui sont mis à mal.
C'est un peu plus mou comme argumentaire, je pense. Mais,
mais ce qui m'a frappé, justement, pour ne pas le citer, ce parti dont on a un petit peu parlé, mais qui a disparu immédiatement après les élections, qui s'appelle Chez Nous,
c'est en fait l'usage des photos de, par exemple, Marine Le Pen dans leur campagne.
Oui, ils ont eu des problèmes avec ça, justement.
Oui, ils ont eu des problèmes, mais je trouve ça frappant pour, donc justement, utiliser l'extrême droite plutôt axée sur quelque chose de très identitaire, très national, etc., d'aller chercher des personnalités françaises quoi.
Oui. Après, ça peut se retrouver aussi, on a une évolution. Historiquement, l'extrême droite est vraiment dans un nationalisme aussi où c'est la nation, le cadre qui détermine l'action politique.
Et donc on va être contre l'Union européenne, contre les institutions internationales, contre les traités et les accords internationaux.
Aujourd'hui, on observe qu'au sein de l'Union européenne, on a une évolution des discours nationalistes où à la fois, on va faire part de la nation, du cadre national, de la communauté,
mais parfois, on va aussi se référer à des cadres beaucoup plus globaux ou plus
généraux.
Par exemple, on va parler de la civilisation chrétienne ou de la culture européenne ou de la culture occidentale, qui est aussi une forme de nationalisme, mais peut-être plus
plus haut, entre guillemets, et qui permet de distinguer non plus, peut-être, pour revenir au cas
belge, le francophone du néerlandophone, mais plutôt l'Européen contre le non-Européen ou le chrétien contre le musulman ou l'Occidental contre l'Oriental, par exemple.
Ça, c'est des logiques qu'on peut retrouver aussi et qui étaient présentes dans des discours de partis politiques d'extrême droite dans le sud du pays également. Oui.
Oui. Donc vraiment, il y a cette idée qu'il y a une centaine d'années, par exemple autour de la Première Guerre mondiale, il y avait vraiment, pour
ce que je vais appeler l'extrême droite ou pour, oui, les pays
dont il est question en Europe de l'Ouest, vraiment cette idée de : c'est nous, c'est nous les meilleurs et on va aller attaquer nos voisins pour montrer qu'on est les meilleurs.
Aujourd'hui, on est effectivement plus dans une logique, comme tu disais, défensive contre, voilà, l'immigration, notamment musulmane, africaine.
Et donc, presque, oui, presque paradoxalement, ce fait qu'on va un peu regarder au-delà des frontières pour s'unir de manière plus internationale.
Oui, on le voit peut-être, par exemple, au niveau de l'extrême droite. Plus précisément, moi, j'ai étudié les discours du FPÖ en Autriche.
Et en fait, le parti politique d'extrême droite, le FPÖ en Autriche, va utiliser justement l'Union européenne avec cette idée d'Europe forteresse comme un cadre protecteur contre l'immigration, contre la religion musulmane.
Et toujours dans cette logique défensive, mais on le retrouve aussi dans tout un ensemble de partis politiques, que ce soit en France ou en Belgique, cette idée aussi, pour protéger les nationaux, on va mobiliser un autre terme.
Encore une fois, les mots sont importants, mais là, je reviens avec ma casquette d'analyse des discours. Les mots sont importants parce qu'ils vont être colorés positivement ou négativement.
Aujourd'hui, nationalisme, c'est perçu négativement. Du coup, on va jouer sur d'autres termes ou d'autres propositions comme la préférence nationale, par exemple.
Ou si on veut plus dire préférence nationale, on dira emploi de souveraineté, qui paraît encore plus atténué.
L'euphémisme du siècle, ça.
Oui, l'idée, c'est de dire qu'en fait, à compétence égale, on va réserver les emplois et les aides sociales et économiques aux personnes qui sont nées sur le territoire.
Oui. Dans, voilà, les outils, les critères qu'on peut employer pour reconnaître l'extrême droite, il y a, de manière assez récurrente, l'obsession avec le complot.
En fait, voilà, le plus connu évidemment ces dernières années, c'est l'idée que, bah, en fait Donald Trump avait gagné les élections, mais on lui a volé.
Plein, plein d'autres complots qu'on pourrait citer.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que, particulièrement l'extrême droite, plus que, il me semble, tu peux me corriger si je me trompe, mais plus qu'à l'extrême gauche, par exemple, l'extrême droite, il y a quand même ce,
cette utilisation de la rhétorique du complot qui est très récurrente.
Oui, alors peut-être parce qu'on va retrouver donc dans les discours nationalistes d'extrême droite, on va retrouver une structure qui est systématiquement mobilisée, qui est cette opposition du nous contre le eux.
Nous les nationaux contre eux les étrangers. Et le nous va être paré de toutes les vertus. On est majoritaire, on est travailleur, on est homogène, on est bon, on est paré de toutes les vertus.
Et donc nous, on est victime de eux. Il y a un petit peu ça aussi.
Et même plus loin que ça, c'est s'il y a des problèmes au sein de la société, s'il y a des crises économiques, des crises sociales, s'il y a tout un ensemble
de problématiques qui vont se poser au sein de la société, ça ne peut pas venir d'un nous qui est foncièrement bon.
Donc il doit venir d'ailleurs. Et cet ailleurs, on va donc désigner un eux, un étranger ou des décideurs et des décideuses politiques qui, en fait, œuvrent à la destruction de la nation, à la destruction du calme.
Et finalement, l'extrême droite va jouer dans cette opposition nous contre eux, elle va recourir en fait au phénomène de bouc émissaire, à la bouc émissarisation de certains groupes.
Encore une fois, ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est que les logiques de bouc émissaire, on peut tous jouer dans ce, entre guillemets, bac à sable-là.
Moi, je prends un exemple très simple. Quand j'arrive en retard à une réunion, c'est pas moi qui me suis levé trop tard, c'est les travaux du tram à Liège, par exemple, ou c'est les bouchons, etc.
Ou c'est mon réveil qui a pas sonné. Ça, c'est toujours la logique de bouc émissaire. Pourquoi ? Parce que l'être humain ne supporte pas être responsable de son propre malheur.
On va rejeter sur autrui.
Là où ça prend une tournure tout à fait spécifique dans les discours d'extrême droite et dans ces théories du complot,
c'est qu'en fait, on va systématiquement recourir à cette logique du bouc émissaire pour expliquer l'ensemble des maux de la société,
que ce soit certaines minorités LGBTQIA plus, que ce soit certains groupes religieux.
Aujourd'hui, c'est concentré autour des personnes de confession musulmane ou que ce soit autour d'une élite, entre guillemets, minoritaire qui s'accapare les richesses et le pouvoir politique contre lesquels il faudrait lutter.
Donc ne serait-ce que, que ce soit dans la matrice idéologique ou dans la rhétorique,
on trouve en fait des facilités et des ponts qui sont très clairs entre la rhétorique d'extrême droite et la rhétorique complotiste qui explique en fait ces liens qui peuvent exister entre les deux.
Et ce qui revient aussi très régulièrement, c'est l'intolérance pour le débat, le désaccord. Il y a une façon de voir les choses et toute autre façon serait une traîtrise, serait, oui, un,
quelque chose de fourbe, quelque chose d'absolument insoutenable.
Il y a pas vraiment la place pour. On va revenir sur justement cette notion de démocratie, de débat, d'échange.
Est-ce que cette,
finalement, ce renforcement de l'entre-soi, de nos opinions d'extrême droite qui sont les seules méritantes et les autres sont toutes mauvaises, est-ce que cette mécanique-là n'a pas été
exacerbée, démultipliée, renforcée par les fameuses bulles idéologiques sur les réseaux sociaux, sur Internet, où on est finalement confronté de base, inévitablement, qu'on soit d'extrême droite ou pas,
surtout à des opinions qu'on partage déjà ?
Oui, oui, on peut en fait voir une domination multiple de l'extrême droite sur les réseaux sociaux et sur Internet, qui ne date pas d'hier.
Tout d'abord, on a ce qu'on pourrait appeler une domination historique, au sens où l'extrême droite a très vite compris que sur Internet ou sur les réseaux sociaux, on pouvait directement toucher les électrices et les électeurs.
Au sens où dans la plupart des États, on reviendra peut-être dessus, mais en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, on a aussi le cordon sanitaire médiatique.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, on met à l'écart les représentantes et les représentants politiques d'extrême droite qui ont un statut particulier.
Donc les partis d'extrême droite ont très vite compris qu'avec Internet, on pouvait directement s'adresser aux citoyennes et aux citoyens.
On pouvait contourner en fait le filtre des journalistes et des rédactions pour s'adresser directement à ces personnes. Je tiens toujours quand même à rappeler qu'un des premiers partis politiques à avoir un site Internet,
c'est le Front national à l'époque en France.
Un des premiers partis politiques européens à avoir une page Facebook, c'est aussi le Front national en France.
Donc on essaye tout de suite d'investir ces milieux-là.
Donc il y a une domination historique. À côté de ça, l'extrême droite est très présente aussi sur les réseaux sociaux parce que ces partis se donnent les moyens aussi d'être présents sur les réseaux sociaux.
Juste un chiffre, mais on pourrait faire l'exercice pour d'autres partis et d'autres pays.
En Belgique, durant l'année 2023, l'année 2024, c'était une année un peu particulière puisqu'on était en période électorale, donc il y a des limitations dans les dépenses des partis.
Mais en 2023, le Vlaams Belang a mis sur la table un million six cent quatre-vingt mille euros en publicité sur Meta.
C'est un montant vertigineux. Si on fait une comparaison avec le premier parti politique
francophone, donc le Vlaams Belang, un million six cent quatre-vingt mille euros, le premier parti politique francophone, c'est le PTB, sur ses pages francophones, a mis cent septante mille euros.
Donc on est sur un ordre de grandeur de un sur dix. Donc c'est incomparable en termes de moyens mis sur la table pour être présent sur les réseaux sociaux.
Donc on a une domination qu'on va dire historique, on a une domination qu'on pourrait qualifier aussi de quantitative en termes d'argent mis sur la table pour être présent sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et après, comme tu le disais, on a une domination qu'on pourrait qualifier aussi de qualitative. C'est l'extrême droite a très bien compris
que en jouant sur les réseaux sociaux avec des contenus courts portés par des émotions très fortes, ça pouvait en fait favoriser l'engagement ou l'interactivité.
On va jouer sur des émotions, alors, mobilisatrices comme par exemple la colère, l'injustice, le sentiment d'impuissance qui font réagir et qui permettent en fait de créer des communautés.
Et comme on le sait, sur les réseaux sociaux, comme tu le disais,
on est enfermé dans des bulles de filtres où on s'adresse non pas à tout un ensemble d'individus, mais à des personnes qui pensent comme nous, qui ont les mêmes codes que nous et qui ont les mêmes affinités que nous.
Donc une fois qu'on sombre ou qu'on plonge dans une bulle,
on est très vite happé par toute une galaxie comme ça de comptes ou d'influenceurs, influenceuses, créateurs, créatrices de contenus qui vont propager le même type de contenu.
Oui, ça renforce donc cet entre-soi, cette exclusivité, cette pensée unique pour reprendre leur terme.
Mais, oui, une campagne, donc, voit effectivement les acteurs, les différents partis publier des programmes plutôt détaillés, des réflexions sur la
façon dont il faudrait restructurer l'État, la société, les dépenses publiques.
Mais une campagne, et là, tu vas me corriger, tu vas me dire : « C'est de la campagne ». Je pense une campagne, ça se gagne principalement sur l'émotionnel, sur le pathos.
Et je pense que la droite, l'extrême droite sont un petit peu les propriétaires exclusifs, les maîtres du jeu en ce qui concerne l'émotionnel.
Ils sont les meilleurs pour la créer de toutes pièces, hein, inventer des paniques culturelles, voilà, Noël va disparaître, etc.
La faire gonfler. On pourrait parler aussi des moyens. Tu l'as dit, les budgets énormes que l'extrême droite arrive à se procurer.
Est-ce que tu es d'accord avec ce constat et est-ce que du coup, ce n'est pas, ben, une fatalité ?
Oui, ben déjà, en termes d'émotions mobilisatrices, il y a des émotions qui sont plus mobilisatrices que d'autres.
On peut le regretter, mais le sentiment d'injustice et de colère fait beaucoup plus réagir que le bien-être et l'empathie, par exemple.
Ça, l'extrême droite l'a bien compris. Donc, elle va avoir une palette d'émotions beaucoup plus large qu'elle va pouvoir mobiliser.
À côté de ça, je renvoie peut-être à un autre élément sur lequel je travaille actuellement aussi, c'est toute la logique des contre-discours et des discours alternatifs.
L'extrême droite va en fait construire sa rhétorique. Finalement, un discours politique, et pas uniquement de l'extrême droite,
un discours politique, c'est un petit peu comme le Seigneur des anneaux pour comprendre comment on fait un discours politique.
On va reprendre le Seigneur des anneaux un instant.
On va reprendre le Seigneur des anneaux. Mais finalement, le Seigneur des anneaux, donc ça nous raconte quoi ? Il y a peut-être pour avoir un bon film ou un bon parti ou un bon discours, il nous faut une valeur centrale.
Le Seigneur des anneaux, on pourrait dire que c'est l'harmonie entre les peuples libres, on pourrait dire.
D'accord, ouais.
Sauf que ça reste très abstrait. Comment on touche l'harmonie ? Comment on filme l'harmonie entre les peuples ?
Et donc on va proposer une quête. C'est un peu le fil rouge du film. La quête, c'est quoi ? C'est Frodon qui doit détruire l'anneau.
Ça nous permet de dresser une histoire et d'avoir d'un côté ce qu'on appelle les renforçants, c'est-à-dire les personnes qui vont soutenir Frodon, Gandalf, la communauté, etc.
Les gentils.
Les gentils. Et de l'autre côté, on va avoir les freinants, Sauron, Saroumane, les Orques, etc., etc. Et un discours politique, ça va être exactement la même chose.
L'extrême droite, elle va jouer sur aussi une valeur comme ça, qui va cristalliser son récit. Cette valeur, il n'y en a pas énormément des différentes.
On retrouve souvent les logiques sécurité, ordre, identité qui sont très présentes. On peut prendre par exemple la question de l'identité, mais l'identité, c'est très difficile à toucher, c'est très difficile à se représenter.
Et donc on va proposer des quêtes. La quête, ça peut être par exemple, on revient là-dessus, mais l'idée de la préférence nationale.
Si vous êtes né sur le territoire, alors vous avez un emploi et vous avez droit à des allocations. Si vous êtes né en dehors, alors on vous retire ces droits.
À côté de ça, il va y avoir des renforçants qui vont pouvoir, le parti politique, certains leaders, certains textes.
Et à côté de ça, on va avoir des freinants, les autres partis, l'immigration, etc. Et donc l'extrême droite, en fait, va proposer des quêtes dans lesquelles chacun va pouvoir se retrouver, faire communauté, partager un sentiment d'identité.
Et ce qui est très compliqué, c'est aujourd'hui, pour revenir sur ta question, c'est que l'extrême droite joue ce qu'on appelle par glissement.
C'est-à-dire que toute remise en cause du programme de l'extrême droite,
l'extrême droite va répondre en disant : « Donc, vous êtes contre l'identité française, donc vous êtes contre l'identité flamande, donc vous êtes contre notre histoire, donc vous êtes contre notre langue.
» Et on va détourner l'attaque de la quête contre la valeur.
Et la valeur est consensuelle et c'est très difficile de sortir d'une valeur parce qu'elles se construisent d'un point de vue individuel, c'est très difficile de dire :
« Je vais changer la valeur ou la façon dont je me représente ma vie et mon objectif sur cette terre », par exemple. Donc
par rapport à ça, il y a des contre-discours, mais les contre-discours, ça attaque l'identité des personnes. Et parfois,
attaquer le vote d'une personne, c'est attaquer sa communauté, c'est attaquer son groupe d'amis, ses parents, sa représentation du monde.
Et donc on se heurte à des sensibilités très fortes. À côté de ça, qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? C'est nécessaire, hein, de parfois avoir des contre-discours, mais ce n'est pas suffisant.
Il faut des discours alternatifs. Un exemple pour illustrer ça, c'est par exemple la question du grand remplacement.
Grand remplacement, donc une théorie d'extrême droite et complotiste qui explique qu'il y aurait de moins en moins de Blancs en Europe et que les Blancs seraient amenés à disparaître.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'il y a des sociologues, il y a des anthropologues, il y a tout un tas de chercheurs et de chercheuses qui ont travaillé sur cette question-là et qui ont démontré,
en reprenant toutes les naissances et la démographie en Europe, que, en fait, le grand remplacement, c'est une théorie juste abstraite qui n'a aucune réalité concrète.
Ça ne fonctionne pas, ça n'existe pas, la théorie du grand remplacement. Donc ça, c'est du contre-discours, dire à quelqu'un : « Mais le grand remplacement, c'est n'importe quoi ».
Sauf que la personne, elle va répondre : « Oui ben moi, dans mon quartier, je le vois bien ».
Mh.
OK. Donc ça veut dire qu'on peut, juste sur notre ressenti, déconstruire un bouquin ou une recherche de six cents pages juste parce que nous, dans notre quartier, etc.
Donc le contre-discours, on se rend compte qu'il est nécessaire. Il faut expliquer, il faut démontrer, il faut argumenter, mais il n'est pas toujours efficace pour toucher les individus.
À côté de ça, donc, il y a cette idée d'avoir des contre-discours, mais des discours alternatifs. Un discours alternatif, c'est vraiment faire un déplacement, un changement de cadrage.
Je prends un exemple toujours dans le grand remplacement. Je crois en la théorie du grand remplacement. Contre-discours, ça n'existe pas.
Discours alternatif, toi, tu crois à la théorie du grand remplacement et moi, je trouve qu'il est inadmissible de laisser des gens mourir dans la mer Méditerranée, par exemple.
Là, on change, c'est-à-dire qu'en fait, on explique que je mets en avant une autre valeur qui est le droit à la vie, comment toi, tu te positionnes par rapport à ce droit.
Et donc, on se rend compte qu'on effectue donc ce mouvement vers d'autres valeurs et on force les individus à changer de point de compréhension.
Moi, je crois qu'avec l'extrême droite et les partis politiques, les chercheurs et les chercheuses, les journalistes, tout un ensemble d'individus ont un réflexe trop rapide d'aller dans le contre-discours.
Mh.
Ce qui, en fait, parfois, attaque l'identité même des individus ou la représentation politique des individus. Donc, il y a une nécessité parfois de déplacer, en fait, le débat.
OK. C'est intéressant. Donc vraiment l'idée que quand on s'attaque, par exemple, à ce réflexe nationaliste, ce réflexe du nous contre le, l'identité nationale, etc.
Donc, ils vont employer systématiquement cette défense, ce bouclier, tu l'as dit, très efficace et qu'on a beaucoup de mal à contrer, de, ben non, mais vous, vous attaquez du coup le,
le sentiment, le nous, et ça, effectivement, c'est mal reçu par la population, par les électeurs.
Et donc, tu dis : « Ben du coup, la meilleure solution, c'est de changer le paradigme », et de dire : « Ben non, c'est pas vous qui vous défendez.
En fait, c'est vous qui attaquez. Et nous, on se défend vis-à-vis de cette valeur qui est la nôtre, qui est le droit à la vie ».
Et là, on renverse le, on renverse le combat, quoi.
Oui, c'est ça. Donc en fait, on est dans des logiques, c'est plus
qui défend une valeur, qui attaque la valeur, mais c'est tu as une valeur et je suis sûr qu'on peut trouver un point d'accroche tous les deux sur une autre valeur que l'on peut partager.
Et plutôt que d'avoir un débat de boxe sur un programme politique, moi, j'essaye en fait de créer un lien avec toi et qu'on puisse réenchanter du commun sur d'autres valeurs.
Mais est-ce que du coup, ça ne devient pas un combat de boxe entre quelle est la valeur la plus importante ?
Oui, mais ça, dans un débat politique, alors, il y a deux, on pourrait dire, idéotypes.
Mh.
Il y a d'un côté les boxeurs et les boxeuses-
Qui, argument contre argument. Et puis, à côté, il faut mobiliser d'autres acteurs que moi, je qualifie les avocates et les avocats qui vont en fait non pas attaquer l'adversaire, mais essayer d'imposer leur valeur dans le débat public.
Et on se rend compte aujourd'hui que l'extrême droite arrive en fait à imposer ses valeurs et ses cadrages. Par rapport à cela, il y a des contre-discours qui sont nécessaires, mais peut-être pas suffisants.
Peut-être qu'il y a d'autres projets à mettre en place-
Mh.
Pour essayer, en fait, de non pas se heurter de plein fouet par rapport à des questions identitaires, mais de pouvoir les analyser sous un autre angle.
Oui, oui. Et donc, on disait, ces stratégies-là, très émotionnelles, très émotives sur les valeurs,
ce stratagème de victimisation, etc., sont vraiment renforcées à coups de budgets monstrueux, financés très souvent par les milliardaires, financés parfois par l'étranger, hein, on pense à la Russie et le Front national.
ça, en fait, quand on regarde tout ça, quand on regarde la mécanique des réseaux sociaux qui favorise certaines émotions en particulier, quand on regarde des stratagèmes bien montés de victimisation, de,
voilà, tu vois, le bouclier, on détourne l'attaque vers le raisonnement, vers les valeurs.
En fait, quand j'observe tout ça, je vois assez peu les réponses que propose, par exemple, la gauche, puisqu'elle a, depuis un peu toujours, hein, ce réflexe de beaucoup de disputes entre soi. On se tape,
enfin, les gens à gauche se tapent entre eux, les partis se tapent entre eux. Beaucoup de mal à décrire, dépeindre un imaginaire, un idéal de demain qui ferait rêver, là où l'extrême droite le fait très facilement.
Donc, en fait, et alors, je vais amener la question sur toi, ta personne, parce que je vois un sticker sur ton laptop qui dit, je crois que c'est : « Non aux idées de l'extrême droite », c'est ça ?
Oui, oui.
OK. Voilà. Alors, en fait, c'est une question que j'aime beaucoup poser aux universitaires, c'est la fameuse question de, et là, je prends des gros guillemets, pour ceux qui n'ont pas la vidéo, la neutralité.
OK.
Est-ce que c'est une question qui se pose quand on travaille en sciences politiques, sur les différents acteurs politiques ?
Est-ce que la question de la neutralité se pose, de, ben en fait, toi, tu n'aimes pas l'extrême droite, si je regarde ton laptop, et si j'écoute ton discours, comment est-ce que ça influe, ça ?
Et du coup, pour revenir à ce que je disais juste avant, est-ce qu'on a la moindre chance de donner une défaite à l'extrême droite vu à quel point leurs outils sont solides et puissants ?
OK. Alors, comment je me positionne par rapport à ça ? Je pense qu'on ne peut pas travailler sur l'extrême droite tout en étant totalement détaché.
Mh.
Ne serait-ce qu'à un moment, choisir un sujet d'étude, c'est avoir une affinité. Alors, je ne dis pas que j'ai une affinité avec-
Mais c'est avoir une affinité avec la thématique ou la réflexion-
Ouais.
Qu'il y a derrière. Maintenant, il y a un positionnement que je peux avoir, moi, François Debras, quand je quitte mon bureau et que-
Tu montres ton laptop ?
Je suis avec mes proches et ce que je pense et comment je vis ou je perçois la politique.
Mais à côté de ça, dans mon travail, il y a une nécessité aussi de-- alors j'aime pas le terme neutralité, je pense que-
Bah non.
...personne n'est neutre, ne serait-ce qu'en choisissant ses sujets, en se positionnant, en discutant. Par contre, il y a peut-être une volonté, c'est de montrer les cartes que l'on a en main.
C'est ça.
Et ça, je pense que c'est vraiment important et comme on l'a fait dès le début, c'est de dire : moi, je suis peut-être pas-- personne n'est neutre vis-à-vis de l'extrême droite.
Mais en tout cas, je vais expliquer comment je définis l'extrême droite, quelles sont les cartes que je mobilise et à quel moment je vais appliquer ou jeter sur la table une paire d'as, par exemple, pour expliquer mon argumentation.
Donc la neutralité, je n'y crois pas. Par contre, la recherche de transparence, ça, je pense qu'elle est importante, c'est-à-dire moi, d'où je parle et comment je construis mon raisonnement pour arriver à cette conclusion-là.
Après, je crois, et ça peut nous amener à la, p'têt la troisième définition de ce
qu'est l'extrême droite. La première, c'est la définition spatiale, donc comme on en a parlé, qui-- comment les partis se positionnent les uns par rapport aux autres.
La définition axiologique, qui est la shopping list : inégalitarisme, nationalisme, sécuritarisme. Et alors, il y a une troisième définition qui renvoie plutôt au domaine juridique,
et qui est définie dans la législation belge sur l'extrême droite, qui est une forme d'opposition à l'État de droit et aux droits humains.
Et là, alors, ça renvoie, et j'embraie là-dessus parce qu'il y a tout un questionnement où
je peux discuter, moi, en tant qu'individu, François Debras,
avec des personnes avec lesquelles je n'ai pas le même avis, je ne suis pas d'accord, je n'ai pas les mêmes compréhensions politiques ou le même positionnement sur des enjeux sociaux, économiques, écologiques.
Mais à côté de ça, je pense qu'il y a vraiment une distinction à faire, c'est il y a aussi des débats qu'on peut avoir dans le cadre et puis il y a des sujets qui sortent du cadre.
Et là, donc je me réfère à la troisième définition qui est plutôt la définition juridique de ce qu'est l'extrémisme en Belgique.
Et pour ce faire, je me réfère donc à la loi organique des services de renseignement et de sécurité du 30 novembre 1998.
Donc la loi organique, on va organiser les services de renseignement et de sécurité en Belgique. Les services de renseignement, ils doivent lutter contre différents types d'acteurs, notamment des extrémistes et des terroristes.
Sauf que si tu connais ou si tu as dans ton entourage des juristes-
Mmh.
...un juriste, il y a quelque chose qu'il ne supporte pas faire, c'est parler d'une chose qu'il ne définit pas dans tous ses aspects.
Les chercheurs aussi.
Oui, oui, oui, c'est vrai. Et donc les juristes, quand, dans la loi organique des services de renseignement et de sécurité, vont mobiliser la question de l'extrémisme, ils vont définir ce qu'est l'extrémisme.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que l'extrémisme, l'article 8 nous dit ceci : ce sont des conceptions ou des visées racistes, xénophobes, anarchistes, nationalistes, autoritaires ou totalitaires,
qui, la spécificité, c'est qu'ils doivent être en contradiction théorique ou pratique.
Donc c'est pas uniquement des actes, ça peut être aussi des discours ou des réflexions, donc qui vont être en opposition, en théorie ou en pratique, à quoi ?
Aux droits humains et à l'État de droit. Et donc là, on a une définition juridique. L'extrémisme, c'est quoi ? C'est une opposition théorique ou pratique à l'État de droit et aux droits humains.
Et si on fait dialoguer toutes ces définitions les unes avec les autres, comment est-ce que l'extrême droite s'oppose à l'État de droit ou aux droits humains ?
C'est exactement ce dont on a parlé tout à l'heure.
Par son inégalitarisme, son nationalisme et son sécuritarisme, on va considérer qu'il y a des individus prétendument supérieurs et inférieurs, certains à qui on doit donner des droits, d'autres à qui on doit les retirer.
Et donc, on se met en porte-à-faux vis-à-vis de la Convention européenne des droits de l'homme et on se retire en fait du débat démocratique de la sorte.
Et donc moi, comment je me positionne par rapport à mon sujet d'étude ? Ben il y a un positionnement tout à fait spécifique de travailler sur l'extrême droite.
Je n'ai jamais voulu travailler sur l'extrême droite,
en étant enfermé dans ma bibliothèque devant un mur blanc. Je pense qu'il y a un nécessaire besoin de rencontres et de dialogues, que ce soit avec des associations citoyennes, des ONG, des militantes et des militants,
ou de faire dialoguer des acteurs.
Et cette réflexion sur les liens entre les définitions, je l'ai eue avec Sibylle Joé, qui est avocate et présidente de la Ligue des droits humains.
Et en fait, on touche vraiment ici au cœur, qu'on retrouve qu'il y a un cœur, en fait, juridique en Belgique, la défense des droits humains et la défense de l'État de droit.
Et c'est un cœur que je fais mien aussi, dans lequel je peux assez facilement me retrouver, dans lequel je me dis : il y a différents types de discours.
Il y a des discours sur lesquels je peux être opposé, et que je verrai comme entre guillemets des adversaires où je ne serai pas d'accord avec eux.
Mais à côté de ça, je pense qu'il y a des discours qui sortent du cadre et le cadre que moi, je défends en tant que chercheur, qui se retrouve à la fois,
dans mon quotidien, dans mon travail, mais aussi peut-être plus largement dans les valeurs qui sont portées par l'université, par l'enseignement ou par la Belgique, c'est la défense des droits humains et de l'État de droit.
Mmh mmh. Et donc tu parlais de présenter, enfin jouer cartes ouvertes-
Oui.
...cartes sur table. Du coup, est-ce que ça signifie que quand tu présentes tes travaux, etc., tu annonces ton positionnement politique ?
Tu annonces ta couleur, tu sors ta carte de parti ?
Non, non, j'ai pas de carte de parti, j'ai pas de couleur politique. Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que, donc le raisonnement, c'est de se dire : voilà, moi, j'utilise des définitions spécifiques.
Ce sont ces définitions-là où je me réfère à ce cadre-là.
D'accord, oui.
Et ce cadre-là, on me donne par exemple un discours, une personnalité ou un parti. Moi, voilà mon cadre qui me permet de dire : c'est d'extrême droite ou ce n'est pas d'extrême droite.
C'est une approche scientifique, une approche objective dans le sens où on définit les termes, quoi.
Oui.
Voilà, c'est ça. Oui, oui. Je veux revenir sur quelque chose que tu as dit beaucoup plus tôt dans notre entretien. Tu as parlé du fait que
les partis démocratiques traditionnels intégraient de plus en plus dans leur discours des éléments qui viennent de l'extrême droite.
Tu as dit que c'était le cas également en Belgique francophone. Ma question, c'est : est-ce que ça marche ? Est-ce que quand on fait ça
On gagne des points, on gagne des voix ou bien est-ce qu'au contraire, on renforce l'acteur d'origine qui est l'extrême droite ?
Alors si on gagne ou on perd des voix, en tout cas, on se rend compte que là où les partis politiques,
entre guillemets traditionnels ont récupéré des thèmes d'extrême droite, peut-être que ça leur a bénéficié dans un temps court, mais ça a surtout valorisé les partis politiques d'extrême droite qui existaient sur le côté.
On le voit par exemple avec les Républicains en France et le Rassemblement national également. Ce,
ce sur quoi je voulais revenir avant de répondre plus précisément par rapport à ça,
c'est si on définit donc de nouveau l'extrémisme, et là, je me réfère à la troisième définition, la définition juridique, comme la mise à mal de la Convention européenne des droits de l'homme et de l'État de droit,
alors effectivement, on se rend compte que ce n'est pas le propre des partis politiques d'extrême droite.
On a en fait une mise à mal de la Convention européenne des droits de l'homme et de l'État de droit
qui peut être mise en place par différents acteurs, actrices politiques, partis politiques, pas définis à l'origine comme des partis politiques d'extrême droite, mais qui peuvent avoir des discours ou des propositions extrémistes au sens de la législation.
Un exercice qui peut être intéressant à faire aussi, c'est si on prend le cas belge, on prend le programme en septante points du Vlaams Blok dans les années nonante et aujourd'hui, on se pose la question de savoir : tiens,
qu'est-ce qui a été débattu ?
Qu'est-ce qui est passé, par exemple ? Et on se rend compte que si le Vlaams Blok, aujourd'hui le Vlaams Belang n'a jamais été au pouvoir,
des propositions à l'origine du Vlaams Blok, aujourd'hui du Vlaams Belang, sont aujourd'hui appliquées ou sont présentes dans le débat public.
Un exemple très simple, c'est la question des centres fermés. Historiquement, la création d'un centre fermé, c'est une proposition du Vlaams Blok.
Le Vlaams Blok n'a jamais été au pouvoir, mais des centres fermés, il y en a qui existent. La création d'un secrétaire d'État à l'asile et à l'immigration, c'est une proposition du Vlaams Blok.
Le Vlaams Blok n'a jamais été au pouvoir. Aujourd'hui, on a eu un secrétaire d'État à l'asile et à l'immigration. Aujourd'hui, on a un ministre à l'asile et à l'immigration.
Donc, ce sont des points qui rentrent dans le débat public.
Alors, il faut être précis et clair aussi vis-à-vis de ça.
Je ne dis pas qu'on ne peut pas parler d'immigration
ou je ne dis pas que toute personne qui parle d'immigration est d'extrême droite, mais ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est qu'on rentre dans des thèmes et des sujets
qui sont construits idéologiquement ou dont les représentations mentales proviennent de l'extrême droite.
Donc, quand on parle de ces sujets-là, il faut le faire avec pédagogie et il faut bien expliquer où on est et comment on peut aborder ces sujets.
Alors, est-ce qu'aborder ces thèmes-là, en fait, renforce les partis ou renforce plutôt l'extrême droite ou leur dessert ?
Tout dépend du système dans lequel on est. Tout dépend des partis qui mobilisent ces termes-là. En France, par exemple, on le voit, on va avoir un durcissement sur les politiques migratoires.
On le voit aussi en Belgique. Si ça peut faire progresser certains acteurs politiques dans un temps court, à terme, ça fait progresser le Rassemblement national.
Et je pense par exemple à la loi Migration qui est passée en France, où Marine Le Pen a applaudi en expliquant que c'était une victoire idéologique de son parti.
Donc ça banalise en fait d'une certaine façon l'original, en disant : on récupère ces thèmes-là, mais ces thèmes-là, en fait, ça banalise le parti qui est à l'origine de ces idées-là.
Donc, pourquoi pas voter pour l'origine directement ?
Ce qu'on dit, c'est pourquoi préférer la copie à l'original.
Oui, exactement. Exactement.
Donc, vis-à-vis de ma question de-- voilà, bon, là, tu vas parler évidemment d'un parti qui penche de plus en plus à droite, qui sont les Républicains en France, mais, voilà, ça peut parfois aussi imprégner la gauche de
manière plus ou moins importante.
Est-ce que-- donc, oui, on préfère toujours l'original à la copie, donc ça ne marche jamais. C'est toujours une erreur de reprendre la logique de l'extrême droite, les combats de l'extrême droite.
Mais en fait, à partir du moment où on parle des droits humains et de l'État de droit, on peut critiquer l'État de droit et les droits humains, mais à un moment, ça se fera toujours aussi au détriment de certaines populations.
Donc, le jeu n'est pas uniquement politique. Le jeu, il touche aussi des personnes, il touche des communautés, il touche certains groupes d'individus. Donc quand,
quand des partis politiques veulent en fait augmenter leur visibilité et être plus présents ou récupérer un certain
électorat en utilisant les thématiques d'extrême droite, on peut finalement avoir une question entre guillemets plus méta qui est de dire non pas quel parti gagne ou perd, mais en fait quelle vision du monde va dominer.
Et si c'est une vision du monde qui joue sur l'exclusion, l'invisibilisation, la domination, l'exclusion de certains groupes d'individus, alors on revient à son cœur qui est des droits humains et l'État de droit.
Et on voit qu'on a un projet de société qui est en train de glisser ou de s'assombrir.
Ouais, ouais. Je vais revenir à l'article que tu as cité un tout petit peu plus tôt, que tu as écrit avec Sybille Gioi.
Oui.
Tu donnes évidemment, tu l'as dit dans cet article, plusieurs outils pour identifier les discours d'extrême droite, ou plutôt différents outils pour les identifier, oui, c'est ça.
Avec notamment l'approche, tu l'as dit, historique, la comparaison, par exemple, avec le discours du Vlaams Blok dans les années nonante.
Aujourd'hui, quel parallèle est-ce qu'on fait dans la communauté scientifique, en sciences politiques
? Quel parallèle est-ce qu'on peut faire entre les mouvements fascistes historiques, voilà, par exemple l'Allemagne des années quarante, et le mouvement MAGA, l'élection de Donald Trump ?
Parce que voilà, on a vu ces images de Steve Bannon, on a vu ces images d'Elon Musk qui faisait des Sieg Heil. Est-ce qu'il y a une comparaison assez claire pour toi, historique, entre ces deux mouvements ?
Alors, c'est pas une question facile à laquelle répondre. On dit toujours : « Comparaison n'est pas raison.
» Et je rajouterais : « Mais est-ce pour autant déraison ? » Mais en fait, ça nous renvoie à tout un ensemble de questions.
Tu as parlé du fascisme et on peut aussi peut-être se poser la question de la définition du fascisme. Extrême droite et fascisme ne sont pas simplement des synonymes qui peuvent exister.
Là, on retrouve en fait les mêmes questions. On peut retrouver une définition plus axiologique avec la shopping list, avec un ensemble de critères.
Et là, par exemple, on peut renvoyer à la définition du fascisme d'Umberto Eco, qui va définir le fascisme comme le culte du chef, le respect des traditions, le rejet de la modernité,
le refus de l'esprit critique, le racisme, le nationalisme.
Donc racisme, nationalisme, on retrouve des liens qui existent.
Mais j'allais dire, dans cette checklist de Umberto Eco que tu présentais, quand même pas mal de points qu'on retrouve-
Bien sûr, bien sûr
...dans le mouvement MAGA chez Trump. D'où la comparaison, ouais.
Umberto Eco va plus loin en expliquant qu'il faut pas cocher tous les critères pour être fasciste. Déjà, un critère, selon lui, est déjà un facteur d'inquiétude ou d'interrogation.
Ça fait donc de Donald Trump quelqu'un de très inquiétant.
Ça fait de Donald Trump quelqu'un de très inquiétant. Mais c'est ça qui est intéressant et je reviens avec mon imaginaire des cartes, c'est quelle carte on joue et pourquoi on la joue.
Certains considèrent, certains chercheurs et chercheuses considèrent qu'on ne peut pas parler de fascisme aujourd'hui aux États-Unis.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le fascisme, c'est un moment T dans l'histoire-
Ouais, c'est ça
...européenne qui se concentre en Italie et certains font des liens en disant nazisme, franquisme, etc., sont proches, etc. Mais-
C'est vraiment l'approche d'historien.
Ouais, ça, c'est vraiment l'approche historique qui peut quand même avoir certaines implications aussi d'un point de vue, certains critères aujourd'hui.
Par exemple, certains chercheuses, chercheurs considèrent que le fascisme, c'est aussi une mise en marche de la société
et que le mouvement MAGA n'est pas tant dans la mise en marche de la société, mais joue beaucoup sur l'apathie de tout un ensemble d'individus aussi, qui ne se mobilisent pas tant, mais
qui acceptent certaines choses petit à petit.
D'autres vont expliquer, et Umberto Eco a un des premiers à le faire, que le fascisme, c'est pas du tout un moment T dans l'histoire européenne,
que c'est une liste de critères et qu'il faut interroger des partis, des régimes, des personnes, des discours en fonction de ces critères-là.
Et là, effectivement, on peut prendre plusieurs critères et on coche en fait des idéologies véhiculées par Donald Trump ou par le mouvement MAGA.
Différents observateurs, observatrices aux États-Unis, des anciens collaborateurs de Donald Trump l'ont qualifié de fasciste en expliquant qu'il cochait plusieurs critères.
À côté de ça, il y a peut-être une autre définition qui peut être intéressante aussi et qui renvoie plutôt au fascisme dans une définition beaucoup plus américaine.
Je pense aux travaux de Sylvie Laurent, qui a travaillé sur la question du fascisme aux États-Unis et qui explique, elle, qu'en fait, le fascisme est lié
à l'histoire américaine en tant que telle, enfin, à l'histoire des États-Unis, pour être plus précis, en tant que telle.
On peut rappeler juste l'espace d'un instant, parce que je pense que pas mal de gens ont pas forcément été mis au courant de ça, mais dans les années 30, 40, il y avait aux États-Unis un mouvement qui s'appelait America First-
Bien sûr
...qui remplissait le Madison Square Garden, donc cet énorme stade de concert, voilà. Et concrètement, on avait, dans les images, on avait George Washington, on avait la croix gammée, on avait les fameux,
les aigles, voilà, romains, américains, les faucons, etc.
Et donc, c'est en fait, oui, c'est ce genre d'exemples-là qui font penser que c'est pas tellement une exclusivité européenne-
Oui, bien sûr. Et Sylvie Laurent, elle explique qu'en fait, l'idée même du rêve américain de la conquête de l'Ouest
renvoie en fait à un imaginaire qui peut être comparé au fascisme puisqu'il repose sur l'idée de la conquête, de la colonisation,
de l'accumulation indéfinie de richesses, le fameux rêve, l'American Dream, mais aussi la domination de certains groupes, notamment les populations originaires des Amériques, notamment l'esclavagisme, etc.,
qui, en fait, jouent sur la ségrégation, l'infériorisation et la domination.
Et que là-dedans, on retrouve en fait des,
des points de convergence avec
l'idéologie fasciste. Et donc le fascisme aurait toute une histoire aux États-Unis, serait dans certains moments, dans des périodes un peu latentes ou dormantes, ou pourrait être réactivé,
à travers certains discours ou certaines personnalités, comme par exemple Donald Trump.
Donc encore une fois, et on revient à ce que tu disais, dire que Donald Trump est fasciste, c'est pas du tout neutre, mais il faut savoir alors quelle définition on mobilise pour argumenter son propos.
Un historien pourrait dire : « C'est n'importe quoi.
» Là où, par exemple, quelqu'un qui serait plutôt adepte de la pensée d'Umberto Eco ou qui suivrait les enseignements de Sylvie Laurent dirait : « Bah en fait, moi, j'ai pas de problème avec cette définition-là.
» Et expliquer que Donald Trump est un fasciste.
Ouais. Donc ça dépend de son approche. Si on met sa casquette d'historien ou si on met sa casquette militant de... c'est Sylvie Laurent, c'est ça ?
Oui. Après, encore une fois, je pense qu'il faut pas toujours opposer ces visions et ces différents acteurs et actrices.
On peut se poser différentes questions en expliquant que
il y a des points de convergence. Et si on faisait le parallèle entre l'Europe des années 30 et les questions politiques actuelles, on peut dire
: voilà en quoi on peut faire des comparaisons et il y a des liens, voilà en quoi il y a des distinctions et des différences profondes qui ne sont pas du tout les mêmes.
Un exemple qui est très cité, c'est l'imaginaire de, 'fin, l'action de l'État fort, c'est-à-dire un État qui va
incarner une puissance, qui va dominer certains aspects de la société, que ce soit le domaine culturel, sportif, éducatif et qui va s'infiltrer dans l'ensemble du quotidien,
des individus, là où aujourd'hui, cet État fort, petit à petit, disparaît, etc.
Donc c'est une très belle réponse de chercheur, puisque tu parles de la méthodologie, finalement, des approches qu'on peut mobiliser.
Maintenant, si on parle de la question en elle-même et qu'on essaie de répondre à la question de, voilà, tu disais, on peut mobiliser ces approches pour répondre à la question.
Quelles sont les approches que toi, tu aurais envie de mobiliser, les réponses que toi, tu aurais envie de donner à cette question, ces parallèles ?
Alors moi, je vais prendre une précaution et après-
Ouais, mais encore une
...je réponds. Mais il y a aussi cette idée que nous, on s'exprime depuis la Belgique en français et donc parfois même les mots qu'on mobilise n'ont pas la même signification.
Mh.
Par exemple, moi, je dis extrême droite, mais aux États-Unis, extrême droite ou même extreme right, ça existe pas vraiment.
On dirait plutôt radical right ou far right, etc. Par contre, à l'inverse, je prends Donald Trump, je le mets en Belgique, j'ai aucun problème à dire que Donald Trump, s'il était Belge, ce serait quelqu'un d'extrême droite.
Mh.
Après, on peut faire la même question sur le fascisme. Je prends Donald Trump, je mets l'étiquette fasciste, quelle définition je peux lui accoler ?
Et effectivement, si on prend, moi, je suis plutôt un adepte des définitions par shopping list qui nous permettent non pas d'avoir une vue relative, mais une vue d'évaluation critère par critère.
Et là, on pourrait dire qu'en lisant, ben, comme je te l'ai dit tout à l'heure, hein, le culte du chef Donald Trump, on le retrouve.
Le respect des traditions, donc on a la lutte en fait contre tous les mouvements un peu LGBTQIA+, contre les changements au sein de la société, le rejet de la modernité, on le retrouve aussi.
L'action pour l'action, on voit que Donald Trump fonctionne de plus en plus par ce qu'on appelle des executive agreement.
Donc essaye de plus en plus de, en fait, contourner le Congrès américain. On passe plus par des lois, par des votes.
On agit directement avec des décrets et c'est le président qui impose son agenda. Donc ça se retrouve aussi. Le racisme, Donald Trump a eu plusieurs propos racistes,
discriminants vis-à-vis de certaines communautés, de certains individus.
Nationalisme, là encore une fois, bon, après, c'est une autre question. Aux États-Unis, le nationalisme est beaucoup plus présent partout dans la société que chez nous.
La guerre permanente, ben la guerre permanente, c'est intéressant aussi. On a tendance à l'oublier, mais Donald Trump, de la période moderne, enfin
récente, j'ai envie de dire, c'est le seul président américain qui a ouvertement parlé de conquête, par exemple, vis-à-vis du Groenland, vis-à-vis du Panama.
Donc on, c'est,
c'est quand même pas anodin, sa façon
de s'exprimer. L'appauvrissement de la langue, on le voit aussi, hein, en tant que chercheur, mais dans le milieu de l'enseignement ou dans certaines administrations, on va supprimer certains termes.
On va supprimer les questions de féminisme, de minorités, de-
Il y a une liste qui est sortie de tous les mots-
Qui est incroyablement longue.
Oui, c'est ça. Il y a genre le mot femme dedans, il y a le mot historiquement.
Voilà.
Une liste de mots incroyablement longue qui est finalement la blacklist des termes qui, dès qu'ils reviennent dans un travail de recherche, signifie que ce travail doit cesser d'être financé,
il doit cesser d'avoir lieu.
Donc oui, ça, effectivement, là, on touche une attaque directe aux libertés et à la s-- on s'attaque à la science.
Oui, aussi, bien sûr, hein. Donc vis-à-vis de ces critères-là, si on utilise ces critères-là pour définir est-ce que Donald Trump est un fasciste, oui, il correspond à ces critères-là.
Mais ça doit dire que un, c'est une définition parmi d'autres et deux, dire que c'est un fasciste ne signifie pas non plus que Donald Trump égale Mussolini en Italie.
Mh, Mh. Bien sûr.
Il y a des différences historiques, culturelles, et, et j'ai envie de dire, en qualifiant Donald Trump de fasciste, ça ne minimise pas le passé non plus.
Il faut bien s'en rendre compte, on n'est pas dans les mêmes univers non plus, où on purgeait certains groupes d'individus, où on assassinait les opposants politiques, etc.
C'est pas la même chose non plus.
Et donc, ça, c'était la précision que tu voulais rajouter ?
Non, donc si on utilise ces critères-là, on peut utiliser le qualificatif fasciste pour Donald Trump, tout en sachant qu'il y a plein de mecs qui doivent venir après.
C'est ça, oui, que tu as bien listé. Et oui, ça aide de la même manière. Ben, par exemple, puisqu'on parle de l'Italie, une Meloni en Italie, est-ce que c'est plus soft ?
Est-ce que c'est une extrême droite plus douce ? Est-ce que c'est aussi fasciste, entre guillemets, qu'un Donald Trump ?
Oui, alors moi, j'avoue que le terme fascisme, là, on a fait l'exercice, mais c'est pas un terme que je mobilise au quotidien-
D'accord, OK
...dans mon travail. Mais par exemple, qualifier Giorgia Meloni d'extrême droite, oui.
Oui, oui. Non, ça, c'est une évidence.
Elle est d'extrême droite. Mais d'évidence, on retrouve certaines interrogations qui peuvent apparaître.
Certains expliquent que ce serait pas nécessairement de l'extrême droite, mais ce serait de la droite radicale ou qu'elle, entre sa période électorale et sa gestion du pouvoir, est-ce qu'on est encore dans les mêmes--
moi, je pense que oui, on retrouve cette idée de l'inégalitarisme, du nationalisme et du sécuritarisme.
Et donc, ça reste de l'extrême droite. On a quelqu'un qui a une vision d'une infériorisation de certains groupes d'individus, d'une nation pensée comme pure et homogène et d'une logique sécuritaire.
Donc pour moi, elle coche les cases de l'extrême droite.
Oui. Donc on a, pour revenir un instant sur les États-Unis, tu l'as dit, on a vu des scènes, voilà, de personnes qui se font arrêter dans la rue sans vraiment de prétexte, qui sont envoyées dans des prisons,
super surveillées dans je ne sais plus quel pays d'ailleurs.
Le-
Oui, je sais plus, j'ai plus le nom en tête, un pays d'Amérique du Sud.
Oui, c'est ça, voilà, où dans une prison, où on ne ressort que dans un cercueil, enfin, voilà.
Et c'est pas, je crois que c'est le chef d'État se définit comme le président le plus cool.
Oui, c'est ça.
Je sais plus, je l'ai sur le bout de la langue.
Voilà, donc une situation aux États-Unis qui est très inquiétante au niveau des droits des journalistes, au niveau des droits des chercheurs, au niveau des populations, voilà, non blanches.
Une question qui revient très régulièrement, c'est le shift qu'il y aurait. Certains, voilà, il y a un article de The Economist qui a souvent été repris.
J'ai un peu du mal à le citer parce que je trouve que les sources et les méthodes qu'il emploie sont pas forcément hyper claires et hyper objectives.
Mais c'est en tout cas une observation qu'on entend régulièrement, quelque chose qui est presque,
tenu comme une, devenu une évidence aujourd'hui, qui serait que
les hommes voteraient de plus en plus à droite, de plus en plus mascus, de plus en plus, voilà, pour quelque chose de très traditionnel, un retour en arrière, un retour aux valeurs fortes.
Et inversement, les femmes seraient de plus en plus dans des logiques plutôt progressives, plutôt de gauche, plutôt féministes et qu'il y aurait vraiment un shift.
Alors bon, je sais pas si on arrivera à répondre à ça aujourd'hui, mais parfois, les gens vont jusqu'à dire que ça devient très difficile pour les hommes et les femmes de se parler pour cette raison.
Est-ce que c'est un constat qu'on fait également en science politique, ce, cette, oui, ce schisme, cette dichotomie entre les électorats hommes et femmes ?
Oui, alors ça, il faut savoir que ça dépend aussi en fonction des pays, ça dépend en fonction des partis et aussi en fonction de l'âge.
Pour prendre un contre-exemple, on se rend compte que, par exemple, en France, le Front national de Jean-Marie Le Pen était historiquement majoritairement dominé par des hommes.
Ouais.
Si des femmes votaient pour le Front national ou Jean-Marie Le Pen, c'est plutôt parce qu'elles suivaient, entre guillemets, passivement leur mari.
Il y avait une vision très passive de la femme d'extrême droite comme ça, qui était forcément une femme qui suivait ou qui était influencée par le représentant politique.
Donc historiquement, le Front national, c'est un parti historiquement masculin et on le voit, les partis politiques d'extrême droite sont plutôt masculins.
Après, Marine Le Pen, elle a essayé justement de retravailler tout ça. Elle va se donner une autre image. Et on a une génération aujourd'hui,
de leadeuses d'extrême droite, que ce soit Alice Weidel pour l'AFD en Allemagne, Giorgia Meloni pour Fratelli d'Italia en Italie
et Marine Le Pen pour le Rassemblement national en France et qui vont essayer de montrer une image à la fois, on va jouer sur les deux tableaux, à la fois d'une image
d'une femme forte, de caractère, qui peut imposer un agenda et imposer ses propositions politiques, mais qui va aussi jouer sur
la sensibilité, l'image de la mère de famille, la personne aimante.
C'est pas anodin de voir que Marine Le Pen, par exemple, se met très souvent en scène avec des animaux de compagnie, avec ses chats, etc.
Ça donne une image un peu attendrissante comme ça. Donc,
on a réussi, enfin Marine Le Pen a réussi comme ça à élargir et à faire en sorte que des femmes puissent se retrouver à voter pour
le Rassemblement national, voire à être membre aussi du Rassemblement national, avec des jeux qui sont parfois du retournement, ce qu'on appelle du fémonationalisme.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va récupérer les thèmes féministes pour les mobiliser contre la personne migrante qui ne respecterait pas l'égalité hommes femmes, par exemple.
Ou plutôt, c'est on va utiliser les valeurs et les combats d'extrême droite et on va mettre une peinture en rose par-dessus.
Oui, c'est ça. Qui, là, il faut bien faire la distinction. Moi, je fais de l'analyse de discours, mais si on compare discours et vote au sein des institutions,
si l'extrême droite, dans certains cas, se présente comme féministe, dans les votes, c'est jamais le cas.
Les questions d'avortement, les questions d'égalité salariale, de lutte contre les violences de genre, jamais l'extrême droite ne vote en ces faveurs-là.
Donc, il y a ce premier élément-là où on a des partis qui vont quand même essayer de s'ouvrir. Pourquoi ? Dans un intérêt stratégique, en fait, d'augmenter le nombre d'électeurs et d'électrices.
À côté de ça, c'est vrai qu'on observe des évolutions, une évolution en termes de l'âge et en termes du genre, comme tu disais.
Historiquement, enfin, généralement, c'était plutôt les personnes âgées qui votaient extrême droite et les jeunes étaient plutôt ce qu'on pourrait appeler des Che Guevara du divan, comme ça, des révolutionnaires dans l'âme, un peu...
C'est comme ça qu'on t'appelait quand t'étais adolescent ?
Non. Mais les personnes âgées avaient plutôt des tendances à voter conservateur, extrême droite, et les jeunes plutôt révolutionnaires.
Mais ça, ça a évolué. Aujourd'hui, on se rend compte qu'on a des jeunes qui votent de plus en plus à l'extrême droite, qui suivent des phénomènes comme ça, comme
Bardella en France ou même le Vlaams Belang en Belgique, qui a très souvent mis en avant des jeunes aussi et une identification du parti beaucoup plus jeune.
On se met en scène dans des cafés, en train de faire la fête, en train de faire des stages, des...
C'est partout, vraiment, à la banalisation, au fait que c'est...
Tout à fait. Banalisation. On essaie d'attirer un électorat comme ça beaucoup plus jeune. Et alors, effectivement, comme tu disais, on va retrouver des jeunes, mais des jeunes plutôt masculins ou des jeunes hommes.
J'avais effectivement vu, genre, je sais plus sur quel média c'était, mais des gens qui avaient suivi un petit groupe de...
pendant la campagne législative l'été dernier en France, qui a suivi un petit groupe de supporters du Rassemblement national, des fan boys, fan girls de Jordan Bardella.
Effectivement, on sentait qu'il y avait une absence complète de radicalisation, de discours raciste, d'anti, anti-woke ou quoi que ce soit.
C'était vraiment un truc du : « Ah, c'est notre mouvement, ah, c'est le meilleur, il est quand même super chouette », etc.
Et on sentait que c'était pas du tout dans une logique politique, idéologique. C'était purement, ils sont chouettes quoi.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais en fait, on revient, je reviens à mon Seigneur des anneaux, mais on revient en fait avec cette idée, on va donner une identité, un sentiment de communauté, de groupe.
C'est être un garçon, c'est faire la fête avec ses copains, c'est manger de la viande, c'est faire de la musculation. Et ça, ça renvoie à ce qu'on appelle l'infra-politique, c'est-à-dire la politisation du quotidien.
Plutôt que de dire : « Vote pour tel ou tel parti », en fait, on va essayer de partager des modes d'action ou des façons de vivre ou des façons d'être.
Ici, par rapport à la question du masculinisme, c'est être un bonhomme, c'est avoir une grosse voiture, faire de la muscu et manger de la viande.
Et donc, on va créer un sentiment d'identité, créer un sentiment d'appartenance. Les partis d'extrême droite vont jouer là-dessus ou certaines communautés jeunes vont jouer là-dessus.
Et encore une fois, rectangle, équerre, c'est pas parce qu'on fait de la musculation qu'on est d'extrême droite, mais on joue là-dessus.
Et une fois, en fait, qu'on a... Politiser le quotidien, on n'a même plus besoin de nous dire pour qui voter.
On va avoir des liens qui vont se faire, entre guillemets, j'ai envie de dire, naturellement, parce qu'on va récupérer les mêmes thèmes, on va avoir la même façon de s'exprimer, la même façon de se comporter.
Et donc ce sera très facile, par mimétisme, d'adhérer à un parti politique. Et effectivement, donc les jeunes garçons sur les réseaux sociaux, on joue beaucoup sur cette valeur identité et sur cette idée qu'il y aurait un,
un « eux », ou plutôt en l'occurrence, là, un « elles », qui nous volerait notre droit d'être des garçons, d'être des hommes, de s'affirmer,
de prendre notre place au sein de la société.
Et encore une fois, on joue sur ces sentiments : injustice, impuissance, colère, qui vont être activés,
non pas dans des logiques directement partisanes, c'est plus subtil, ça contourne, mais plutôt dans des logiques d'identité, d'appartenance, de sentiment de communauté, qui après, on peut mobiliser contre et on revient toujours au nous contre eux ou elles.
Mh. Et donc vraiment, c'est cette idée de,
encore une fois, les seuls qui ont en main les leviers de la défense de la masculinité, c'est l'extrême droite, et ne se retrouvent pas, par exemple, dans les discours de gauche, des discours qui vont
séduire les hommes en se disant : « Ah voilà, enfin quelqu'un qui nous donne le droit d'être des hommes et on est bien dans notre peau, on est des hommes, c'est très bien, etc.
» Au contraire, il y a... En fait, c'est... Je me souviens que j'avais lu ça, des gens qui demandaient à des hommes pourquoi ils n'avaient pas voté pour Kamala Harris aux élections présidentielles américaines.
Et revenaient, par exemple, le fait que, quand on va au meeting de Kamala Harris, il y avait des t-shirts avec écrit : « The future is female », que,
à chaque fois qu'on entendait le mot masculinité, c'était avec le mot toxique juste à côté, et qu'il y avait finalement un petit peu ce sentiment qui revenait assez régulièrement de,
: « On n'est pas les bienvenus ici », quoi.
Mh.
C'est quelque chose qui se retrouve dans...
Je sais pas, mais en... Faudrait creuser ces questions-là, mais en t'écoutant, je retrouve vraiment cette idée que on touche à des sujets aujourd'hui qui ont été en fait,
dont les représentations mentales sont dominées par des discours d'extrême droite.
Mh.
Et donc en fait, c'est très difficile d'aborder ce sujet sans à un moment être simplement dans de la récupération de discours d'extrême droite ou dans du contre-discours qui, à un moment, attaque donc les identités des individus.
Donc, il y a un nécessaire besoin de reconstruction et d'avoir des discours alternatifs comme ça qui peuvent apparaître.
Après, je crois qu'il faut pas
idéaliser non plus d'autres groupes. Je pense que les discours masculinistes ne sont pas le monopole de l'extrême droite et que des discours masculinistes, on en retrouve tout type de,
partis politiques confondus et parfois dans du quotidien, dans la rue ou quand on parle avec des gens.
Donc c'est pas non plus uniquement un thème lié à l'extrême droite.
On l'a dit en intro, maintenant que tu donnes cours un petit peu partout en Belgique francophone. Est-ce que quand tu donnes cours à des plus jeunes, tu observes un petit peu cette dichotomie de
des jeunes garçons qui sont quand même un petit peu antiféministes et des filles qui sont au contraire très mobilisées par ce sujet-là qui était féministe ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu observes dans le concret, au quotidien ?
Mais en fait, peut-être par rapport à ça, donc moi, j'ai eu la chance pendant deux ans de faire une recherche pour la Communauté française sur la perception de l'extrémisme chez les jeunes.
Ok.
Donc je suis allé dans des écoles, quand je dis les jeunes, ils sont pluriels et multiples, mais je suis allé dans des écoles de secondaire discuter avec des rhétos, tout type de filières, tout type d'indices socioéconomiques.
J'en ai rencontré entre sept cent et huit cent, plus ou moins. J'ai fait passer des questionnaires et j'ai également fait ce qu'on appelle des focus groups avec eux.
Donc, j'en tirais au sort par classe entre sept et quinze, je les mettais autour d'une table et je les faisais discuter entre eux.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'il y a des logiques qui reviennent
assez rapidement. Je me suis rendu compte très rapidement, donc, que, par exemple, c'est toujours les petits gars qui prennent la parole en premier et qui essayent un peu de monopoliser la parole.
Et donc faut faire attention pour avoir un temps de parole assez équilibré, parce que c'est vrai qu'ils ont une certaine volonté comme ça à tout de suite réagir, discuter.
Et finalement, il y a les paroles des filles ou des femmes qui étaient beaucoup plus invisibilisées. Donc faut faire attention à ces logiques-là.
C'est pas juste chez les jeunes, ça.
Non, non, pas du tout, pas du tout. Et alors, autre élément qui est revenu dans leur discours,
c'est que effectivement, la question de ce que certains percevaient, entre guillemets, comme de l'extrémisme féministe était présent dans certains discours.
C'était pas du tout, donc c'était pas une recherche quantitative, donc je saurais pas te quantifier à ce sujet,
mais c'est revenu dans plusieurs tables de discussion, cette idée que l'extrémisme, c'est ne pas écouter l'autre, c'est imposer ses idées.
Et selon certains jeunes, qui étaient pas que des garçons, d'ailleurs, expliquaient que...
Et le féminisme serait l'extrémisme.
Oui, c'est ça. Qu'il y avait une certaine forme où on nous imposait un discours, on ne peut plus dire, on peut plus rien dire, etc.
Qui s'est retrouvé dans quelques tables de discussion. Donc oui, du coup, ils en arrivaient à avoir une certaine forme d'agressivité en retour vis-à-vis de ces logiques-là. Oui, oui.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Au niveau, voilà, de la responsabilité, parce qu'on approche la fin, on va parler un petit peu des réponses institutionnelles.
Au niveau de la responsabilité des acteurs médiatiques, voilà, on a parlé de banalisation il y a quelques instants. Je reste marqué à tout jamais à ces images de, c'est quoi ?
C'est Karine Le Marchand, c'est ça, sur M6 en France, où l'accueil des politiciens, politiciennes de tous les horizons.
Et c'est, on va parler du petit chien, on va parler de la tablette, de jouer avec des drones, la vie en famille, etc.
Et donc oui, les Marine Le Pen, les Jordan Bardella sont tout à fait des gens normaux comme les autres.
Et là où, historiquement, on a quand même plutôt eu autrefois, il y a longtemps, une approche de diabolisation par rapport à ces personnes-là.
On mettait principalement en avant leur haine, leur haine d'autrui, leur haine de la différence. Aujourd'hui, c'est bon, c'est des gens comme les autres, c'est un discours comme les autres, c'est banal, etc.
Je parle de la France là parce que ça m'a particulièrement marqué, mais, en Flandre évidemment, y a pas vraiment de,
de barrage médiatique, de cordon sanitaire médiatique vis-à-vis de l'extrême droite, donc ils sont aussi dans les jeux télé, dans la télé-réalité, etc.
On peut aussi parler du financement de structures médiatiques par des milliardaires qui ont vraiment poussé des logiques éditoriales très très conservatrices, très fortement marquées à l'extrême droite.
quelle réponse apporter à cette responsabilité des médias ? Est-ce que, encore une fois, est-ce que l'extrême droite qui met en avant surtout des discours très fort axés sur l'émotionnel, le pathos,
va évidemment très fort profiter de cette tribune.
Oui, quelle réponse apporter à cette observation ?
Alors, je crois qu'y a différentes façons de répondre à cette question. Peut-être un premier élément auquel je pense, c'est que,
aujourd'hui, on se rend compte, et il faut pas toujours pointer du doigt les journalistes, y a un manque aussi de financement, parfois de temps, d'approfondissement, etc.
Mais moi, j'ai l'impression que souvent, quand j'écoute des débats télévisés,
français où y a des personnalités politiques d'extrême droite, c'est que c'est un débat qui tourne beaucoup sur la forme et très peu sur le fond.
Là, comme tu disais, on a Jordan Bardella qui raconte un petit peu sa vie, qui se met en scène. Marine Le Pen, on la prend comment, au Salon des agriculteurs, avec des animaux, on discute, etc.
On la montre comme proche des gens. Et finalement, on a peu de débats sur le fond et les propositions en tant que telles.
Je tiens quand même à rappeler que le programme du Rassemblement national, en tant que programme politique, est inapplicable en France parce qu'il est contraire à ce qu'ils appellent le
cœur des valeurs républicaines qui touche à la fois,
à la Constitution, également à la Convention européenne des droits de l'homme, à tout un ensemble de législations, comme par exemple contre le racisme, etc., la préférence nationale.
En fait, on peut pas appliquer ce genre de choses concrètement en France sans mettre à mal tout un ensemble de législations, d'éléments juridiques, institutionnels très présents.
Et ça, je pense qu'on ne le souligne pas
suffisamment en expliquant que, derrière toute la forme qui est mise en place par l'extrême droite, la façon dont on se présente, derrière, on a des programmes qui sont profondément opposés aux valeurs
du pays ou des normes européennes ou qui sont en contradiction avec des institutions et des textes légaux.
Donc il faut jouer là-dessus et je pense qu'il faut appuyer là-dessus. Autre élément qui me vient en discutant et en parlant de ceci, c'est quand on voit les débats présidentiels,
en France au second tour d'Emmanuel Macron contre Marine Le Pen, on observe finalement que Marine Le Pen connaît très mal ses dossiers en tant que tels.
On la voit chercher dans ses feuilles sur le plateau télé.
Oui, ou parfois, elle se trompe d'un dossier à l'autre. Donc en fait, elle connaît assez mal ses dossiers et je pense que c'est un élément sur lequel il faut appuyer également.
Autre élément, arrêter de faire plaisir à l'extrême droite en parlant sans cesse d'immigration, immigration, immigration, islamisme, islamisme, islamisme.
Ben en fait, c'est des thèmes dans lesquels eux sont à l'aise et ont l'impression de pouvoir dérouler leur tapis, et les prendre sur d'autres thèmes et d'autres enjeux de société sur lesquels ils sont beaucoup plus mal à l'aise.
C'est des thèmes sur lesquels ils sont à l'aise et c'est aussi des thèmes qui font de l'audimat, qui font du clic et que du coup, les médias vont être tentés de...
Là, c'est vraiment un serpent qui se mange la queue. C'est en fait,
l'extrême droite parle d'insécurité, les journalistes relaient ce que dit l'extrême droite sur l'insécurité, les gens se sentent en insécurité, donc vont écouter les discours d'insécurité.
Enfin, donc on est dans une boucle comme ça. Et ça, on l'a vu aux élections quand Chirac s'est retrouvé contre Le Pen au second tour.
Les journalistes ont expliqué que peut-être qu'ils avaient un petit peu trop parlé des banlieues, d'insécurité et d'immigration pendant la campagne.
Donc je crois qu'il y a une responsabilité à avoir là-dessus. Après, y a une autre... y a une spécificité quand même en Belgique francophone, c'est qu'il y a le cordon sanitaire médiatique qui existe.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que le cordon sanitaire médiatique, c'est pas que l'extrême droite, ça ne touche pas spécifiquement à l'extrême droite.
Si on retourne dans le texte, donc, c'est un décret de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, hein, donc c'est contraignant.
En fait, dans le cordon sanitaire médiatique, c'est-à-dire qu'on ne tend pas le micro en direct à des représentants de partis ou de mouvements qui ne respectent pas trois choses.
La première, c'est la législation contre l'incitation à la haine raciale, la deuxième contre toute forme de discrimination, la troisième contre le négationnisme.
Et certaines chaînes, la plupart des chaînes, pour ne pas dire toutes, vont rajouter en plus, et on retrouve toujours le même cœur qui se retrouve en fait un peu partout, c'est le respect de la Convention européenne des droits de l'homme.
Donc on explique, les journalistes en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles expliquent que en fait, ces discours-là sont tout à fait spécifiques.
Il faut pouvoir les encadrer parce que le direct ne permet pas d'avoir un filet de sécurité par rapport à des propos négationnistes, homophobes, discriminants, haineux.
Et donc il faut se donner un filet de sécurité pour cadrer le propos si on a un dérapage en direct. Donc le direct est impossible, donc on fait du différé.
Le cordon sanitaire médiatique, c'est ça, en Belgique francophone, c'est ne pas tendre le micro en direct à des représentants de mouvements ou de partis qui ne respectent pas, donc Convention européenne des droits de l'homme,
législation contre le racisme, discrimination et négationnisme.
Donc ça, c'est un outil que tu juges comme étant plutôt efficace.
Ouais.
Mais une fois que l'extrême droite est installée, par exemple en Flandre, trop tard, on peut plus...
Ah oui, donc
le cordon sanitaire médiatique, il est pas exportable. On pourrait pas dire : on va l'appliquer aujourd'hui en France, on va pas l'appliquer aujourd'hui,
en Flandre parce que, en fait, on a une extrême droite qui est déjà bien présente.
Donc là, c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qu'on a en Belgique francophone, qu'il faut protéger, qu'il faut sauvegarder, mais qui n'est pas forcément transposable dans d'autres logiques.
Mmh. Ben donc, oui, si cette réponse-là, on ne peut pas l'exporter, qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait apporter comme solution concrète, vraiment présentable ?
Oui.
Par exemple...
Toujours dans le domaine des médias ou aussi...
Principalement les médias et puis on va conclure sur les institutions démocratiques.
OK, parce que dans les médias, alors, je pense qu'il y a un nécessaire encore un travail de pédagogie, d'explication et parfois de faire attention aux mots que l'on mobilise.
Et moi, je reviens avec ma casquette d'analyse des discours. L'extrême droite, c'est des partis, ce sont des partis politiques, ce sont des idéologies, ce sont,
des représentations du monde, mais c'est aussi parfois des mots et que l'on retrouve au quotidien.
En disant ça, je pense notamment à certains termes qui sont présents dans le débat public et qui, en fait, originellement, proviennent de l'extrême droite.
Un exemple très simple, la théorie du grand remplacement, donc théorie complotiste et raciste qui nous provient de l'extrême droite et qui, en fait,
aux dernières élections présidentielles en France, certains journalistes posaient telle quelle la question à tous les candidats aux élections présidentielles : comment vous positionnez-vous par rapport à la théorie du grand remplacement ?
Il ne viendrait pas à l'idée de poser la question : comment vous positionnez-vous en tant que futur président ou présidente par rapport à la théorie de la terre plate, par exemple ?
Enfin, ou alors, on explique, on justifie. Donc ça, ce sont des termes,
grand remplacement, qui se sont imposés dans le débat médiatique et je pense qu'il faut soit les retirer, soit avec pédagogie, expliquer que ce sont des discours racistes et complotistes.
Il y a le grand remplacement, mais il y en a d'autres. Quand on parle de décivilisation, quand on parle d'ensauvagement, quand on parle de vagues migratoires.
En fait, tout ça, c'est des termes qui sont historiquement d'extrême droite et qui ont été récupérés dans le débat public.
Et qui n'ont pas de base scientifique, mais du coup, qu'est-ce qui explique que, ben en fait, on n'observe pas ces réponses, ces déconstructions et ce fait de ramener ces discours à la réalité.
Pourquoi est-ce que on observe cette espèce de passivité que tu décris ?
Alors, je crois qu'il y a quand même des journalistes qui le font hein. Il faut pas...
C'est un exemple, mais c'est quand même, voilà, le service public, le service public télévisuel français, par exemple, trop passif par rapport à ces discours-là.
Ben alors, je pense qu'il y a un manque, parfois un manque de moyens et de temps pour certains journalistes. On a de moins en moins de journalisme d'investigation, d'analyse.
On a beaucoup ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui du desk journalisme. Donc, c'est des personnes qui sont à la rédaction et qui font leur travail via
Internet, les réseaux sociaux et qui s'informent uniquement depuis leur bureau.
C'est pas toujours de leur faute hein. C'est aussi un manque d'argent qui est mis pour l'investigation et le traitement médiatique.
Et alors, autre logique aussi, je pense qu'il y a un intérêt, tu parlais du service public, mais aussi à chérir un certain service public et une presse indépendante et libre, pas forcément
publique au sens financé par l'État, mais en tout cas, avoir une presse libre, comme tu l'as dit, avec des médias qui sont liés au groupe Bolloré en France.
On a aussi monsieur Sterin, par exemple, avec le groupe Périclès, etc. Qui peuvent en fait mettre des machines comme ça, alimenter la structure.
Ce ne sont pas des exemples de presse libre, hein.
Non, pas du tout, pas du tout. Qui sont justement l'inverse, qui sont des presses qui sont au service d'une certaine vision du monde. Donc ça,
il y a toute la question de la régularisation par rapport au monde des médias,
par rapport à certains types de contenus et essayer de favoriser justement une diversité des médias et ne pas avoir des grands groupes comme ça qui vont vraiment avoir-
Donc soutenir financièrement le journalisme indépendant, le journalisme d'investigation,
et oui, et soutenir évidemment un service public de qualité, ce qui est évidemment plus difficile à mettre en place puisque ce n'est pas les citoyens qui ont les mains là-dessus.
Et donc, voilà, ça, c'était pour les questions médiatiques, au niveau institutionnel, au niveau plus global, démocratique.
Oui. Alors, je vais prendre un exemple français pour illustrer mon propos. Différentes études socio-géographiques montrent qu'en France, plus on est éloigné d'une gare, plus le vote du Rassemblement National augmente.
Donc ma solution, c'est de construire des gares partout. Non, mais,
l'idée, c'est en fait, on observe qu'en France, plus on est éloigné d'un, du service public au sens des trains, de la poste, d'une administration communale,
plus on est aussi éloigné, par exemple, d'une pharmacie de proximité, d'un médecin traitant.
C'est-à-dire qu'on doit prendre sa voiture, rouler,
plusieurs dizaines, voire heures pour atteindre, quand on est dans des déserts un peu médicaux comme ça, où on se rend compte qu'on a un vote d'extrême droite qui est beaucoup plus présent parce qu'il va jouer
sur ce sentiment des laissés pour compte, des oubliés,
des abandonnés, etc.
Et à l'inverse, on se rend compte qu'en fait, en Belgique francophone, en Wallonie, on a un maillage associatif très fort, par exemple, qui est aussi une des façons d'expliquer l'absence de partis politiques d'extrême droite.
On a dit tout à l'heure l'absence d'idéologie nationaliste en Belgique francophone. On peut parler du cordon sanitaire médiatique aussi, qui empêche la visibilité ou même la connaissance des partis d'extrême droite.
Mais le tissu associatif, et notamment syndical, est une des raisons qui explique aussi l'absence de partis politiques d'extrême droite institutionnalisés dans le sud du pays.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir en fait un maillage d'associations qui vont pouvoir faire communauté, écouter les gens, dialoguer avec les gens, parfois entendre une colère et la rediriger.
On a en Belgique francophone des syndicats qui sont très actifs aussi dans la formation permanente, l'éducation populaire, dans la lutte contre l'extrême droite également, avec, parfois, ils sont,
les premiers lanceurs de villes antifascistes, provinces antifascistes, communes antifascistes.
Tout ça, parfois, ça peut se résumer simplement à des slogans et des symboles, mais derrière, il y a aussi des actions dans la formation continue qui peuvent en fait aider et lutter contre l'extrême droite.
Donc, je pense que ce n'est pas le travail d'un seul individu ou d'un groupe d'individus. Les journalistes ont une responsabilité, ont des actions à mettre en place.
Les enseignants comme moi aussi, finalement, aller dans des écoles, dialoguer, faire des conférences, faire rencontrer des personnes, c'est aussi une responsabilité et c'est aussi une action pour lutter contre l'extrême droite.
Après, d'un point de vue global, soutenir des associations, soutenir des organisations citoyennes, tout ça aussi, c'est une façon de lutter contre l'extrême droite.
François, merci beaucoup.
Ben merci à toi aussi.
C'est un peu plus que septante minutes passées ensemble. Je te dis à très bientôt. Au revoir.
OK. Merci.
Je remercie François pour avoir fait le déplacement. Vous pouvez retrouver ses livres Fake news, désinformation, un enjeu démocratique aux éditions du Centre d'action laïque, ainsi que Le chant des sirènes : quand l'extrême droite parle de démocratie chez Peter Lang.
Et enfin, son podcast PopEx sur le populisme, l'extrémisme et le complotisme est dispo sur toutes les plateformes habituelles.
J'ai mis les liens en description. Et de même, si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné à Septante Minutes Avec, n'hésitez pas, on approche des cent épisodes.
Il y en a tout plein, plein de belles archives à parcourir. Dans les semaines qui viennent, vous allez retrouver Isabella Lenarduzzi de chez JUMP pour parler sexisme au travail et ce sera aussi bientôt le retour d'Olivia Gazalé dans le podcast.
Je vous dis à très vite. Salut !